[Музика]
Я можу сказати, що вдало, я маю на увазі абсолютну
впевненість, яка ґрунтується на цих
подіях 2014 року та влітку, що це були
ці артилерійські тексти не просто
помилки чи випадковості окремих
командирів, це була систематична
спроба російських військових  знищити
українські сили, які були розміщені
вздовж кордону, і на основі
доказів, які ми маємо з цього звіту, ми можемо
сказати, що це був акт війни
Російської Федерації проти України
[Музика]
можливо, деякі уряди не бачать
користі  надавши всі ці докази того, що
Росія веде вогонь по Україні, тому що, можливо,
це негативно вплине на політичну
ситуацію в якийсь спосіб, що вплине на ту
чи іншу сторону, я не можу
сказати напевно
[Музика]
[Оплески]
ви